chello
it's as American as apple pie and twice
as wobbly and while it is translucent
today we'll see what's really inside the
key to the query concoction is collagen
the fibrous protein that makes flesh so
tough and stretchy which is why jell-o's
recipe starts as chopped up pig and cow
hides soaked in acid or alkaline after
which collagen
triple helix of amino acid chains relax
and unravel in a hot bath of h2o as it
cools the substance stiffens into a
colorless odorless fibrous matrix and
since the resulting gelatinous
flavorless as well sugar is added to
sweeten the pot while adipic acid pulls
your taste buds into sensing fruitiness
when none exists by adding a tart jolt
of sour to all that sweetness as does
fumaric acid hydrophobic compound that
repels moisture to preserve the desert
in its powdery form
disodium phosphate and sodium citrate
may also help killer mold its flavor
with a dash of saltiness but more
importantly his buffering agents keep
the gelatin Gellin by stabilizing the pH
balance to prevent excess acidity just
as jello prevents picnic lunch
predictability with many unofficially
flavored variations from mock melon to
simulated strawberry in a Wiggly rainbow
of petroleum-based artificial flavors
though the fun of jell-o is always 100%
real feeling wired yet subscribe